sources tell us a correctional officer
was exposed to a substance initially
believed to be fentanyl while searching
a prison cell earlier this week that
officer was seen at a hospital and is
okay this happened at High Desert State
Prison that's about a 40-minute drive
outside of Las Vegas the Nevada
Department of Corrections confirming
this happened but a spokesperson saying
she doesn't have additional details to
provide at this time now we don't know
whether any inmates are facing charges
in connection with this incident this is
the same prison where an inmate was
murdered after his cellmate issued a
warning and where there was a cluster of
inmate suicides we do know Staffing is a
major issue at the Nevada Department of
Corrections and there is an issue with
drugs getting inside state prisons but
again at least one correctional officer
exposed to what is believed to be
fentanyl that officer expected to be
okay though back to you I said Thank you
and as the 8 news now investigators
first reported back on Thursday come
Monday the Nevada Department of
Corrections will have a new director
James render returns he had resigned
from the same position in 2019 and
Governor Joe Lombardo is bringing him
back